we are mortgaging the future our
children grandchildren future
generations while at the same time
reducing relative investments in their
future at a time that they're going to
have increasing competition that's not
only a responsible it is immoral
I have Nicol SP with Reason TV today
we're talking to David Walker the
president and CEO of the Peter G
Peterson foundation and former US
Controller General David thanks for
talking a you talk a lot about federal
financial responsibility what what is
the magnitude of the problem facing us
in terms of fiscal responsibility or
lack thereof well last year fiscal 2009
we had a one point four two trillion
dollar deficit this year it's going to
be one point three trillion plus the
debt has more than doubled in the last
ten years it's scheduled to more than
double again in the next ten the tolive
isn't that kind of growth good and that
type of growth is not that's called
negative growth but and you know our
liabilities unfunded promises have
tripled in the last ten years as well
what it what are the major drivers of
this out-of-control government
liabilities Medicare is 38 trillion
dollars underwater Social Security is 7
to 8 trillion dollars underwater those
would be the two biggest what are the
types of spending restraints that are
meaningful that we might put in or
Congress might put in on itself and then
how do we how do we say not necessarily
safe how do we make Social Security and
Medicare either
less you know horrible disasters or more
viable guns well first we need to learn
from the past
we need to reimpose tough statutory
budget controls on discretionary
spending we need to be able to have
mandatory reconsideration of spending
programs and tax policies when they
reach a certain size what does that do
well what that means is is under the
past you know spending controls that we
had we control what was called
discretionary spending which is defense
and other spending but we didn't have
any controls and all that over 60% of
the budget that there's in there by law
that are the mandatory spending programs
you know Social Security Medicare
our medicaid agricultural programs a
trillion dollars worth of tax
preferences deductions exemptions Cluj
ins credits those just grew on autopilot
weren't subject any constraint or any o
of oversight we also need to have pays
you go rules that are real meaningful
pay-as-you-go rules the ones that are
there right now have trillions of gaps
in here here's a speaking of pay go
President Obama has said you know what
we're not going to spend a dime unless
we're cutting a dime one of the recent
issues is the constant re-upping of
federal unemployment benefits Jim
Bunning became a national laughingstock
when he said you know if you want ten
billion dollars to pay for this take it
out of whatever it is for trillion
dollar budget and he was laughed at more
recently
the Congress just again agreed to redo
or spend more on unemployment benefits
without cutting anything how do you make
these things stick how do you make
pay-as-you-go work well first it's very
difficult to be able to constrain
federal federal spending especially in
the area of unemployment benefits when
you have almost ten percent unemployment
and you've got so many Americans that
are hurting if you will but I think you
know this is kind of an example of you
know when things aren't going well
people want to do more and they may have
justification for doing more but when
things we're doing are going well they
don't want to end up making tough
choices to be able to eliminate a bunch
of things that aren't working and that's
what we have to do I mean we have to be
more future focused more
results-oriented
government has grown way too big we have
a lot of federal government spending
programs and tax policies that don't
work was there in recent memory you know
was there a time when pay-go rules
actually worked or where congress
restrained at least the growth in
spending if not absolute cuts from 1990
to 2002 due to the efforts of President
George Herbert Walker Bush 41 and
William Jefferson Clinton we had tough
statutory pay-as-you-go rules
discretionary spending caps etc and by
and large they worked they helped
provide discipline they helped to give a
basis for people to say no why did they
here they disappeared because as you
know we had a surplus for four years
people thought that we didn't have a
problem anymore and frankly people
didn't want to be constrained with
regard to spending or tax cuts they
wanted to be able to do both and they
did a lot of both and now we're much
worse shape than we've ever been talk
about Social Security how big is the
problem and what do we do to to adjust
things Social Security does not face an
immediate crises but it is paying out
more and benefits than it's taking in
and cash revenues and and that will
never reverse right as well it's
supposed to it's supposed to reverse for
a few years less than five years after
we come out of the recession but it's
permanently going to be negative cash
flow starting in about 2017 you know we
need to recognize that it's prudent to
solve it sooner rather than later we
need to gradually increase the normal
and early retirement ages and then
indexing the increases in life
expectancy strengthen the benefit for
people into the poverty level provide
not quite as much for middle and upper
income and we need to add an automatic
savings account on top of a solvent
sustainable secure defined benefit
program let's talk about Medicare what
do we do with Medicare this this is the
thing that it will bring us to our knees
right well there's a lot of things with
Medicare we need to move away from
fee-for-service payment systems we're
going to go to more evidence-based
practices we can't write a blank cheque
for Medicare which we do now we need to
be more realistic about what type of
services should be covered under
Medicare we need to get out of the
business of providing subsidies for
billionaires and very wealthy people who
voluntarily sign up for Medicare as
outpatient physician payment and
prescription drug programs should we get
rid of the prescription drug benefit I
mean this is one of Bush's big legacies
it's a total black hole and it's shovel
it really shovels money from relatively
poor and young people to relatively
well-off and I think the federal
government was in the wrong business for
health care I think the federal
government over the next 20 years or so
should be in the business of making sure
that every American has preventive
wellness and catastrophic so guaranteed
insurability had group rates for those
things but beyond that I think that
there ought to be choices ought to be
options and Americans shouldn't be
required to take it beyond that
I think if we did something like that we
could do something would be affordable
and sustainable for our broad-based
societal benefit but what we have now
and frankly what we recently did I think
is going to compound our problem so that
and I mean obviously essentially what
the health care reform in a lot of ways
was that just passed is really creating
Medicare for everybody now or it's
certainly massively expanding the
government's role in regulating and
quite possibly ultimately in delivering
health care what do we do to pull that
back what how do you reach people to say
you know these systems are unsustainable
now Medicare is unsustainable adding
another you know trillion dollars in
healthcare spending over the next decade
or more is unsustainable what do you do
well what Washington just did is they
added a new wing to a health care
account house that it's structurally
unsound mortgage for more than it's
worth and headed for foreclosure sooner
or later people are going to realize
that and then we're going to have to
have an honest discussion debate with
the American people about what level of
health care coverage is appropriate
affordable and sustainable and how to
best finance it all the tough decisions
dealing with that were really punted and
I think it's probably gonna be 2013
before we come to make those decisions
but we must make them there is no way
that economic growth is going to save us
I know there's something called math in
order for us to be able to grow our way
out of this problem it would take
double-digit real economic growth every
year for decades it hasn't happened it's
not going to happen
and we also can't inflate our way out
either talked briefly about the Peter G
Peterson foundation what's its mission
and what's your role there well the
Peter G Peterson foundation is named
after a great American Pete Peterson who
puts his money where his mouth is and
his time where his heart lies we're
about promoting federal financial
responsibility we want to make sure it's
not an oxymoron we want to be able to
promote more you know responsibility and
accountability today so we can help
create more opportunity tomorrow we're
focused on fiscal issues savings issues
balance of payments issues basically
trying to help save the Republic are you
optimistic about the future or
pessimistic I'm an American so by
definition I'm optimistic at the same
point I'm I'm a realist and my view
is yes we can turn this thing around but
only if the first three words of the
Constitution come alive
we the people but aren't the people the
problem I mean they're the ones I mean
everybody wants something you know
you're talking about you know if it's a
75% subsidy on health care I'm paying a
quarter I'm getting a bucks worth of a
look human nature being what it is okay
everybody wants as much as they can get
and not have to pay for it but what they
have to understand is it's not just an
economic issue this is a moral issue we
are mortgaging the future our children
grandchildren future generations while
at the same time reducing relative
investments in their future at a time
that they're going to have increasing
competition that's not only a
responsible it is immoral and it's also
taxation without representation on a
massive scale thanks David for talking
good to be with you names with David
Walker of the Peter G Peterson
foundation and former controller of the
United States
I'm Nichol SP for reason TV
you